and scored if you don't got it
jones jaren
that was nasty don't have the open look
we're moving the ball to someone else
who is getting the open look you look at
the points in the paint first quarter
orlando won that 16-2
14-4 for the grizz
franchise record is 21 threes in a game
for the grizzlies he'll try
again you've got to be kidding me
adrenaline from jaren jackson junior
here in this third
listen i'm not going to the basket take
a step back i don't matter if you're a
seven footer off the glass i heard him
call glass
with a rejection another rebound out to
tucker
and the mets take it away moran
what a move and what a finish by jared
jackson jr
houston wow
wow wow wham
irving against morant
irving blocked by morales we're going to
overtime
one of the best players on the planet
against a rookie
and a rookie meets the moment well he
does it he
stays down doesn't jump for the head
fake and then
is able to use his size and length to
come up with
a huge block on kyrie irving i almost
forgot though they could have gotten the
ball and called the timeout
houston by percentage here's valentine's
missing brandon clark
[Applause]
made people feel any other way with this
two-hand
finish here up above pj tucker and yes
that is
your starting point guard for the
memphis grizzlies
grizzlies lead is three marantz slips
through a little showing go
off the window an incredible play by
john
watch the young fella here go behind
your back split the
fake the defender take away finish this
off off the glass and some knows no
words it's just
zeller with the foul morant can't
convert the three-point play
[Applause]
morant down the lane lays it up
it is holy cow with seven
tenths of a second john morant
but on this one there's not a struggle
it's just about athleticism
strength and the wherewithal to finish
amongst three
hornets defenders loves to go left loves
to finish with that left hand is able
to squeeze through zeller and get the
left hand finished
still time left on the clock the bridge
had to play d but what a fantastic
finish not a young fella amongst the
trees well
jaw 11th in the league and fourth
quarter scoring comes out to anderson
here is moran turning on the burgers oh
my
wow what a ridiculous finish from
john morant in the back move from john
moran well just
watch where he starts it that starts at
the free throw line
into the chat 20 for mitchell 27 for
buck donovan
valencianas leads the grizzlies with 22
job
[Applause]
reaching in
[Applause]
so utah is over the limit so there still
will be free throws
[Applause]
as high as 33 against milwaukee
mahrez down the lane and powers it in
gobert did not challenge
and it's a three-point game
morette with a running start elevator oh
my goodness
[Applause]
i mean watch this this is with 40
seconds to go
in a tight game crosses them going away
from the basket
throws it in and it is a function of how
many times he drives to the rim but jaw
gets
a lot of his shots blocked
nifty move there that's not going to get
blocked
[Applause]
start and finish here to this second
quarter salomon hill off the pump fake
morant with a pump fake oh better hit
that
yeah whoopsie uh-oh
jerome robinson and that oh changes no
they're going to
stay this way and whoa whoa whoops
whoops where'd he go where'd he go
okay hold on let me compose myself and
then knock it down
he had to come up with he had to compose
himself first because after you make the
move it's like
okay that did happen and he's not going
to get back
[Music]
stolen by morant job
with the reverse
and he did that in the face of an
all-star
great hustle great anticipation by
morant
and then he can just create when he
jumps here and it's like well let me see
what i don't want don't get that i'll
turn around
creating opportunities yes this building
will become electric
see if this happens now
these guys really love playing with one
another
and they play together in such a nice
fashion we always talk about morant
what will he do we'll partner brooks
against
[Applause]
dylan step back gun
[Applause]
holy cow phoenix moran now is 17-8 in
the quarter
[Applause]
nobody for him and come here
come get some of this
clark covered up by porter five to shoot
morant works against craig on the
baseline
still with it and somehow reverses it oh
my gosh
[Applause]
michael malone was arguing for an
offensive foul here
that is amazing they have retooled
nicely
you lose anthony davis you can't do
better than what they were able to put
together
[Applause]
is okay in this part if he didn't come
down with his hands but how about that
throw finn look where he catches the
ball listen the ball is nowhere near the
bass look
and that's a lob for mid-court look at
that
morant five to shoot job
got caught in the air shot clock down to
two desperation three
put it in holy cow ice water in the
veins from the rookie
knocked the ball away you know what i
gave you a 26-footer
the grizzlies haven't been a three-point
shooting team all night but i tell you
this much
this young fella is a winner through and
through he only knows how to play
winning basketball and because of that
this grizzlies team
is in the playoff hunt right now marantz
he has two of the grizzlies five triples
tonight
there we go
what a tandem right there transfers to
oakland had a red shirt gear
and goes underneath him smooth 360
action
it's just too easy uh you know humble
guy here
as we see john moran with a smooth 360
finish
don't try that at home ladies and
gentlemen
trying to get valentine's flashing in
the post miranda goes
over the top